la temperatura cerca de julieta entre
belarús y polonia ronda los cero grados
celsius la madera se ha vuelto un bien
preciado para calentarse alrededor de
una fogata se estima que son unos 2.000
migrantes los que se aglutinan en este
punto buscando llegar a polonia y este
miércoles con un aumento de los intentos
por cruzar la frontera dice el gobierno
de varsovia esta es una crisis que
comenzó hace meses pero tuvo su punto de
giro este lunes con cientos de asaltos
simultáneos por intentar pisar el suelo
polaco una maniobra orquestada asegura
varsovia a lo que nos enfrentamos
debemos ser claros es una manifestación
de terrorismo de estado así es como lo
llamamos polonia afirma también que
belarús ya respondía así a la condena
internacional por las cuestionadas
elecciones de agosto y las sanciones
aplicadas en solidaridad con polonia
charles michel presidente del consejo
europeo comenzó una visita en varsovia y
no descartó la aplicación de más
sanciones contra minsk
la respuesta de belarús llegó a través
de su canciller y desde rusia su gran
aliado el sitio frontal continúa el
chantaje político contra el estado
bielorruso ya se habla en occidente de
un quinto paquete de sanciones el motivo
esta vez en la propia crisis provocada
por la unión europea y sus estados
miembros limítrofes
en este contexto de sanciones estamos
enfocados en el trabajo consolidado con
los colegas rusos y el apoyo mutuo
incluía una respuesta conjunta con
respecto a las acciones hostiles contra
nuestros países les tiene triste próxima
versión veleros insiste en que polonia a
vivir a las leyes internacionales al
bloquear el paso a los migrantes y
además también golpeando estas personas
la discusión política parece estar en un
punto muerto mientras que naciones
unidas hizo un llamado a resolver una
crisis migratoria que califica como
intolerable